so has brad wright's plans for stargate
had to change
thanks to amazon and their influence
welcome to sidetrek your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
so we all know that brad wright has been
talking about stargate for anything up
to four years definitely the last two to
three
he's spoken very openly with amanda
tapping and
michael shanks about their characters
possibly returning but then definitely
being involved behind the camera amanda
tapping is a quite in-demand um tv
director now she's done lots of projects
over the last 10 years and michael
shanks obviously did direct
several stargate episodes as well
but i do think michael shanks is
possibly more going to be tapped up to
actually return as an acting role we
want to see daniel jackson back on our
screens don't we
but brad wright has obviously been
working on this project for nearly four
years he's been developing a story he's
been developing a project
now it is true
that when mgm had full control over this
before amazon's influence really got
stuck in
that they were planning to do a return
to tv series a live action tv series
and an animated tv series
according to my source the live action
tv series is going to be contemporary is
going to be in line with the storyline
so it's going to be
16 years after sg-1 ended
and it's going to be a continuation of
that story the plan is to
sort of
sort the sgu
plot line out that will be actually we
will have an answer to the sgu
end of the series
there will be other answers as well to
what happened with stargate atlantis all
of that was planned to be explained in
the live-action tv series but as part of
a different storyline so it's going to
be a new story
however they will go back to
those elements of the different series
from before
and like i said answer some of our
questions
the animated tv series was supposedly
going to be an anime style cartoon
animated series that was going to
actually be more to do with the ancients
and was going to maybe jump in and
around the timeline of the ancients and
maybe explain some of the questions that
we have from sg-1 stargate atlantis
sgu
maybe even
how the destiny was launched in the
first place things like that
those plans though have been scrapped
there will not be an animated series at
all
even though some of the elements of the
storyline that are planned are being
merged into things like the game
now
stargate timekeepers coming out in 2022
is going to be important to brag right
plans because the storyline
for that game for timekeepers is planned
to be included into
the following movies and tv series that
are now planned
so just to be clear the old tv series
and animated series has been scrapped
however the story that brad wright has
been working on for last four years
hasn't
the general plot that he has planned is
going to continue but however amazon
want them to do it a different way
because when they took over mgm one of
the first things they did was when they
looked at this franchise and a couple of
others is they told mgm to think
bigger
they don't just want a tv series and an
animated tv series they want movies they
want a game that interlinks all these
things they want online games mobile
games they want
maybe an animated twos in the future but
i think that's been shelf pretty much
they want tv series that interlink with
each other they look at what marvel have
done
how all of their different
projects that go on the what if series
the tv series on disney even the netflix
tv series and then obviously the movies
and then the games how they all
interlink with each other they all add
to each other they're all canon so how
does that affect brad wright well he
most definitely has gone quiet since
around may
with his project he was very vocal and
i've said to you in the other video he
was very vocal because he was told to by
mgm it increased the value of mgm if
stargate is a viable project otherwise
it's just part of the back catalog
its value isn't maybe as high but as a
viable project its value goes up a
little bit
they can negotiate more money with
amazon
amazon aren't throwing the baby out with
the bath water they want to keep all of
that hard work that's been done and they
want to keep brad wright on side they
know that any big amazon project has to
have brad's write's name to it or the
fans will go apeshit what happens on
social media is a massive influence on
amazon they know what goes on on social
media they watch it
this is one of the reasons why stargate
is 100 getting
a new series very very soon because they
know how much people are still
interested in it
the first video i did on this
subject got a hundred thousand views
my second video has just gone past 30
000 views people are interested in
stargate but this will not be a reboot
it seems to be that amazon are very
interested in continuing the existing
storyline again
it's not like other projects like say
book rogers that's going to get a reboot
soon that hasn't been around for 40
years stargate sg-1 still does really
good business for
amazon sgu does
so does target atlantis
they're purposely taking them off other
servers like hulu because they want all
of their eggs in their own basket they
want to take advantage of this and they
don't want anybody else to
so the new series will most definitely
reference stargate sg-1 stargate
atlantis and stargate universe this new
tv series and subsequent movies will
most definitely
answer the questions that we have
following sgu because every time
the new series references sg1 sgu and
stargate atlantis
they're going to see a spike in views of
those shows as well
amazon are not stupid
and they are going to take full
advantage of this
a reboot would anger fans and it would
also mean that those other series maybe
don't get a spike in views because you
can't reference them
so just to be clear this will not be a
reboot it will be a continuation of the
story
mainly because amazon want our money
we can look forward to brad wright still
being firmly in control of lots of
aspects of this series
even though with amazon's thumb very
much
on his head controlling what he does in
the next video i'm going to be talking
about when this is going to happen and
that is a little bit complicated but it
does seem that amazon have a very
specific plan in mind
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out
please go to the discord server the link
will be in the description where you can
talk all about stargate and meet other
people that are interested in this
and go to our facebook channel link is
also in the description you can dump all
of your silly little memes you can have
conversations with people i put all of
our videos and any information i come
across straight on there myself
thanks very much guys and i look forward
to seeing you next time when i'm going
to tell you all about when we're going
to see stargate return
[Music]
you